welcome back to CBS this morning right
now it's time to show you some of this
morning's headlines The Verge reports at
Amazon's 1 billion dollar acquisition of
an online pharmacy proves it's serious
about disrupting the healthcare industry
pill pack sells and chips pre-sorted
doses of medicine to customers homes
around the country the news sent shares
of drugstore giant CVS and Rite Aid and
Walgreens plummeting costing them about
11 billion dollars in combined market
value Amazon reportedly beat Walmart
which was also in talks to buy pill pack
Walmart has no comment at this time
Newsweek reports on a study that
suggests sing the DA the same doctor
could be a matter of life and death
researchers in the UK looked at data
from nine countries including the u.s.
82 percent showed patients who went back
to the same physician had a lower chance
of dying compared to patient patients
who visited different doctors patients
who stick with a physician are generally
more satisfied more likely to listen to
their doctor's advice and have a higher
chance of taking preventative measures
bloomberg reports that Kroger the large
US supermarket chain is countering
Amazon with plans for self-driving
grocery delivery Kroger will begin pilot
tests of its driverless cars this fall
at an undisclosed US store the unmanned
cars could help cut down on delivery
times and possibly the cost customers
will need to be home when their delivery
arrives to unlock the grocery order
Amazon bought Whole Foods last year and
has added to our delivery program for
its prime members and the Washington
Post reports that America's cheese
stockpile just hit an all-time high
there's almost 1.4 billion pounds
stockpile that's a 16 percent since 2016
when the government had to buy more than
90 million pounds of cheese to cut the
surplus of dairy supplies analysts say
that higher milk production coupled with
lower demand for milk have increased
these cheese stockpiles milk is more
easily stored and cheese the Miche
movement ignited a global reckoning on
sexual harassment and abuse now the New
York Times is revealing how the movement
changed the brave women and men
who shared their stories the time spoke
to 20 people who previously came forward
Ashley Judd was the first actress to
accuse movie producer Harvey Weinstein
of sexual harassment and abuse Weinstein
has denied the allegations
judge ho that told The Times quote I
think we can safely say millions of
others are here to offer support and
hope nobody can do it for me but I don't
have to do it alone CBS News contributor
Jody canter is an investigative reporter
for The New York Times in Mullane arise
ik is a cultural reporter for the paper
they're reporting helped expose sexual
harassment and abuse and fueled the me2
movement The Times won a Pulitzer Prize
for its extensive reporting Jody and
Molina good morning and great to have
you with us your name rocked by reading
this article and recalling all of these
women and men's stories
what made you Jodi now decide to go and
revisit them and see how they're doing
well going on the record is such a
difficult thing to do in this instance
and we wanted to go back to the women
and there's also a man in the package to
see what happened later and we we felt
like we wanted to stay with the story we
knew that we knew that we knew that this
was kind of a moment but we don't think
that moment is over it's continuing to
play out publicly and it's also
continuing to play out in the lives of
the people who participated in it and
these were public lives many of them
Ashley Judd being the first she told you
that she felt liberated that that she
felt that she had comfort in some of
these other women can you talk about
this network that they somehow managed
to form comforting each other and
thriving off of each other coming
forward well some of them are formal and
some of them are informal there are a
lot of instances in which survivors
people who have experienced abuse have
banded together in actual groups and
then some of it is just really informal
and this kind of ineffable feeling that
you know everybody feels that this
happened to them individually but we now
see that this was a pattern that it was
something so much larger and what was
striking to us in our original reporting
and is still striking in the responses
is the commonality
these women and men don't know each
other totally different backgrounds
different economic type backgrounds and
yet the things they say are so some
stories are the same Elena I like at the
beginning of the piece you wrote there
was emotional fallout careers were on
the line yet there were a few regrets at
last their voices mattered what were the
women saying what are you hearing from
the women what they say you know a lot
of them felt like this was an emotional
roller coaster just having this
experience of speaking out and that was
one of the reasons that we wanted to
tell this story because I started
hearing from some of my sources very
soon after the stories were published
last fall you know the aftermath is a
complicated process and we want to talk
to talk about that you know one of our
sources felt like the attention that
came to her after she told her story
after she told the story not even just
you know the process of talking about it
and and the people that came to her and
wanted her help as a survivor it says
she said I needed mental health help to
get through that and another person said
you know after years of going to therapy
weekly I realized what I needed to heal
was this was talking about I don't need
therapy so we really heard a very
diverse array of reactions and that was
one of the things that we wanted to
highlight people respond to this in so
many different ways and there were
implications for their careers mostly
positive not all we had one woman drew
Dixon who was in the music industry who
had to leave the music injury industry
who was basically forced out of it by
some of this misbehavior and now she's
back in the recording studio yeah she
accused music mogul Russell Simmons of
rape Simmons of course has denied the
allegations
she says telling her story was like I'm
quoting her here like a weight had been
lifted from my shoulders explains some
of the changes that she went through
yeah I mean she said that she didn't
even know how heavy that weight was
until she put it down which I thought
was really evocative I mean you don't
even know what you're carrying in some
cases how big this burden is and you
know these people have sometimes kept
this secret for sometimes 20 30 years
and all of a sudden to see it exposed in
this way to see it on the front page of
the New York Times is a really powerful
moment in their lives I would like to
know how you both are hearing or what
you're hearing from men either men who
were perpetrators or men who say that
I'm now looking at this conversation and
my action
differently that is the case we're
hearing very little from the
perpetrators on the whole with other men
I'd say there's a big difference between
the public conversation and the private
conversation and in many ways it's the
private conversation that is the most
powerful we're hearing about lots of men
groups of men who have gotten together
and just had you know really searching
conversations of have I ever done
anything that's upset anybody how would
I even know about it
what is the set of rules that I grew up
with and and how does that set of rules
need to be revisited now you think men
are still confused milena that's
certainly what we've been hearing and I
think one of the other reasons that we
decided to do this packages to for
people to understand what the stakes are
in coming forward what the effect is
what the effect of this behavior is I
think one of the things I heard in the
fall when a lot of this reporting was
going on is people not really
understanding why women would want to
come forward or what happened to them
afterward and again that's what we
wanted to talk about to see you know
this behavior impacts people for years
sometimes it might just be you know a
moment in the office a moment where you
brush up against somebody at the coffee
machine but that's something that sticks
with somebody and changes their feelings
about how they're there their workplace
and their professional ambitions
sometimes so you know you have to think
about all of that conduct and certainly
the hope is that talking about this so
much in the open this way will change
people's ideas about what is and isn't
acceptable but I think people still
wonder is there a way for men to make
amends and move forward you know so that
they can so that they can recover or
that they can return I don't know if
that's if that is possible it's
questions a lot of people are asking
yeah and it's you know heartening to
know that there are some people that are
telling their stories but there are so
so many who are afraid to tell their
stories and afraid of the repercussions
that's what we wanted to do we wanted to
give people out there a sense of if you
actually go forward if you do the brave
thing here's the way you may feel
afterwards incredible reporting is
always Jody Kanter and Melina rising
thank you both for being here we
appreciate it